[музика]
коли для мене сьогодні дуже велика честь
бути в Києві і представлятися до цього
світу хочу привітати Україну з
величезними успіхами які вона вже
досягла на шляху до освітньої реформи
досить емфіційний цілі і Крім того ми
бачимо що незалежна щоб вона належним
чином просувається на цьому шляху
на початку всіх інших
Союзу
ось так
[музика]
ми вважаємо що до почесність та
справедливість Я завжди центром
будь-якої форми тому ми хочемо
подякувати нашим партнерам зокрема це
повний відкрите суспільство завдяки
якому можемо сьогодні презентувати у
друкованій формі ось цих звіт щодо того
як Україна може покращити свою ситуацію
з доброчисністю у світі
нам працювала
і я знаю пані міністр що насправді був
віддані ті меті щоб тільки не краще
нерозумніші учні могли отримувати
найкращі можливості а не просто тільки
походить із них багато слів
мови
слово
в тебе знову
і крім того найсерйозніші порушення
є дуже публічним ми не побачите що за
порушниками виїжджала поліцейська машина
якщо щоб проходили якісь судові
впровадження натомість це невеличке
порушення які трапляються щодня стільки
звичними що вже можна сказати з тих
частиною прийнятної практики
наприклад
слово Ісус
пам'ятаєте коли ви останнього разу
приїхали на червоне світло світлофора
але точно не пам'ятаєте всі рази коли
проїжджали на зелене і таким чином ці
невеличкі порушення стають таким зеленим
світлом світлофора як я вже є
прийнятними на які не звертають увагу
обов'язково
[музика]
у цьому світі вони зосереджувалися на
якихось конкретних порушень певних осіб
чи певних установ натомість нашим
основним акцентом було покращене
загальною політики для того щоб змістити
систему і таким чином покращити і
принципи доброчесності
[музика]
Відповідно ми зосереджувалися на ризиках
доброчесності тобто тих стимулогів і
змушують людей порушувати закони правила
та норми а також говорили про те як
можна зміцнити правила для того щоб
покращити систему моніторингів
[музика]
просто
Відповідно ми дивилися на проблеми з
доброчесністю які є притаманними для
всієї української освітньої системи
починаючи з дитсадку я ж дивлюсь щось
любити
відповідно наприклад коли ми розглядали
питання дошкільної освіти тому дивилися
опять може зробити більш справедливим
доступ до неї для дітей
дивилися на те як
шкіл можуть використовуватись більш
прозорим справедливим
шляхомлинського
чи ми дивилися на визнання навчальних
досягнень Справедливих ми прозорим чином
я у школах університетах
Ми дивилися на питання приватних
додаткових занять я хочу репетиторства
який часто вчителі надають своїм власним
учням
[музика]
власності
і також дивилися на питання академічної
доброчесності саме в університеті
Комісарів
ці
і для кожного з цих видів ми давали
аналізи але також окремі рекомендації до
змін зміцнення самого системи
один із наборів рекомендацій режим на
тому як саме запровадити належним
стимули до покращення доброчесності
[музика]
участо бачили що певні порушення
наприклад цих габарити подарунки а також
пропорційний доступ часто засновані на
законодавчі рекомендованій системі яка
створює для цього стилю
[музика]
відповідно наприклад У деяких містах
України не вистачає місця дефікат тому
їй системі батьків для того щоб вони
шукали якісь шляхи обходу
Олександр
у вищій освіті ми часто бачили що
студентські роботи оцінюються навмисно
належним чином бо надто високо понадто
низько тому що від цього залежить певні
формули фінансування навчального закладу
і ми бачили що Часом буває так що
система захочуть і неточний оцінювання і
навпаки не дає можливості оцінювати
справедливу систему
і
якого Анна але вам сказати що уряд
України уже розробляє політику певний
галузенятості з цими проблемами
наприклад щодо доступу до місії дитсадка
був створено систему електронної черги
яка допомагає зменшити людський фактор
під час доступу
дизайнер
Action
крім того є також можливість
передивитися формули фінансування вищих
навчальних закладів для того щоб вони не
підпадали дистанції коли навпаки
намагаються зміцнити доброчесність у
навчанні
[музика]
другий набір рекомендації в нас
стосується балансування саме автономії
установ для того щоб не були самі
приймати рішення з іншого боку їхню
прозорості підзвітності може сказати що
це найскладніша частина нашого звіту
нашої рекомендації пішов на каналі
[музика]
Добрий вечір тобі коли його паску
найближчого
а часто може бути дуже спокуслим
механізувати піропротезувати кожен
процес для того щоб ніби туди не могло
пройти жодне порушення і таким чином
звести ці порушення до мінімуму але якщо
люди самі не були усвідомлювати Навіщо
це потрібно Вони все одно будуть
знаходити вхідні шляхи
[музика]
Ендрю беленс ззаду на екрані
ракурсіків
зараз російською ми вважаємо що потужний
спосіб у зміцнення доброчесності цього
випадку це збільшення професійної
відповідальності автономії з одного боку
але також вертикальне розвіт людськість
горизонтально тобто щоб відповідали
тільки перед урядами компетентним
органами але також перед вашими колегами
батьками і суспільством загалом що воно
теж стало повноправним учасником процесу
таке політичний
наприклад добре що батьки мають з
могу додаткові фінансові ресурси для
освіти але вони з іншого боку можуть
також стати до громади яка буде
наглядати за їхнім новим використанням
[музика]
причин тому що ці батьківські кошти не
враховуються в шкільний бюджет тому що
система звітування вона є надто складною
коли ви вже затвердився лише один раз на
початку року після того вносити зміни
стає дуже важко відповідно потрібно дати
більше гнучкості але з іншого боку і
більше прозорості так звітності як ми
розуміємо нові реформаторські ініціативи
з промо- спрямовані також і на це все
відбувається
і це мене проводить до останньої частини
наших рекомендацій а саме це зміцнення
інституційної спроможності для того щоб
і батьки і
школи і громади загалом працювали саме в
цьому році
[музика]
насправді
позитивішу іншу сталовали те що сталося
пенсіонерська
область
як приклад може наприклад назвати
покращення великих прогресу доступі до
Миколаївської програм шляхом
запровадження зовнішнього незалежного
оцінювання завдяки цьому це сталося
більш чесними підзвітним так само
подібні інструменти можна
використовувати більше галузі які
встановлював стандарти надавали зовнішні
валідацію Таким чином якщо буде при
цьому надаватися належне навчання і
підтримка можна буде зміцнювати
наявність освітню історією вересня
і мабуть не можна перевищити важливість
тих рішень які ви сьогодні приймаєте
щодо освіти тому що ваші школи сьогодні
це ваше суспіль
ство
[музика]
і крім того ті принципи доброчесності і
взагалі справедливості які будуть
відчувати молоді люди навчаючись у
школах університетах вони будуть
відчувати їхні сім'ї також впливатиме на
їхню подальшу поведінку і прийняття
рішень в дорослому житті
йшов
Слава болить ефекту
driverdale
яким чином
я економі
дослідження усе показують що краще
навички серед випускників різних
навчальних закладів не тільки їхню
більшу бізнес не тільки їхнім кращому
участь в економіці і краще зарплатні і
шанси на працевлаштування але також їхні
більше громадянські залучення Вони
сприймають себе як люди які можуть
змінити ситуацію якось вплинути те що
відбувається і порівняно з тим люди які
не мають належать до єдиного навпаки
вважають себе тільки об'єктивно
політичним волі відповідно належна
освіта належні навички шляхом до більш
свідомого суспільства
і знову ж таки від імені оселя мають
сказати що ми дуже вражені позитивно
пані міста тими кроками які вживаєте на
шляху до реформи і тим у вашому
зусиллями щоб покращити освіту заради
кращого майбутнього ви можете
розраховувати на наші подальшому
допомогу дитини